Okay.
Uh,
we're going to pick up where we left
off with talking about Mark's last time.
And,
um,
there towards the end of today's lecture,
there'll be some quotations that I'm
putting up on the slides to talk about.
You shouldn't try and scribble them
down. Uh, they're too long for that.
And I put the slides up on the,
on the server so you can,
you can find them there. It's
better to follow them. And,
and the argument that I'm making,
so I was just talking to some of the tea
teaching fellows about how the sections
went and it seemed like there was some
confusion or lack of, um, what's the word?
A lack of comfort with this
concept of exploitation in Mark's.
Just where does it come from and how
does exploitation occur when people are
buying,
making voluntary paredo exchanges.
And I think that is the
right question to zero in on.
And we're going to spend more time on it,
uh,
both today and next time because it really
is important for Marxists argument to
work that exploitation is
not about cheating people.
It's not about getting people
to do things in voluntarily.
The, the idea behind the concept
of exploitation is equivalent,
is it changed for equivalent use
values a voluntarily exchange.
So another way of putting it,
it if you like, is that, um,
the transaction between the employer
and the worker is a parade. Oh,
superior transaction and marks
is not claiming that it isn't.
So then you might say, well, what
is this idea of exploitation?
And we saw that in some ways it's
quite counter intuitive because,
um, when we, when we
worked through this, uh,
the only way in which the capitalist can
increase his productivity is by either
increases in what Marx called
absolute surplus value,
which is basically lengthening the working
day, getting people to work harder.
They're obviously physical limits to that.
And political limits workers
are going to organize,
they're going to get the 10 hours bell
passed through parliament as they indeed
dead. Um, and so then you get, um,
the, the other approach, what he called
increases in relative surplus value,
which is technological innovation so
that the capitalists can cover his wage
bill in less time.
And so this,
the,
the
okay
necessary labor time goes from
four hours to three and there's um,
seven hours of surplus labor time where
the workers producing goods that when
sold produce value that
does not accrue to them.
Okay.
We thought there was,
there was some in coward counterintuitive
here and we're going to come back to
that in that most of you figured you
would choose three over Cho if the
alternative,
if you had to take one of them,
but that's actually a higher
rate of exploitation. Uh,
and I started talking about
the assumptions about how
people compare themselves.
Remember the self referential versus
other referential and we'll come back to
all of that.
Um,
but the point I want to make first and
to get you just clearly to understand is
that this,
these,
this kind of move increasing productivity
by technological innovation is marks
and modern economists all agree is the
thing that makes capitalism dynamically
productive because it's,
it's the,
it's the pressure to innovate that
is created by a capitalist competition
that leads to technological innovation
and more and more, um, more and more
capital intensive production.
Because if you think about it,
the more you're spending
on PR on technology to make
your labor more productive,
the less you're spending on your wage
bill and it's only living human labor
power that creates fresh
value according to Marx,
and so what we were, when we think
about this line moving this way,
we thinking about production
becoming evermore capital intensive,
right? More and more spent on
technology to make the pro,
the the workers more productive and
we should expect capital in a capital
intensity to increase over time.
When you see Mark's talk about used
phrases like the organic composition of
capital increases,
he's just saying that that productions
becomes steadily more capital intensive.
Now you could say,
well,
why is this exploitation and
Mark's once to say this is,
I think at the end of the day,
not a very plausible argument for
reasons we'll see on Wednesday.
He wants to say,
this is not a moral argument.
This is not a normative argument.
He's jumped.
He's using it as a technical term.
And so the fact that people don't feel
more exploited in this circumstance then
in this is neither here nor there.
It's,
it's true in the class in itself
since that I talked about last time,
that they objectively speaking,
are more exploited.
He has an argument about why they will
eventually come to feel more exploited.
That will attend to a
little bit later today.
But for right now,
um,
he's just wants to say this
is an object of argument.
Now you could say, well, so is the rate
of exploitation the rate of profit?
And the answer is no,
it's not the right of profit because this,
the value that's created here,
the song called variable capitol,
which just covers the wage bell,
is separated out from capitol
that's spent on everything else.
So it's true that the capitalists
profit comes out of here, but,
but so rant, uh,
research and development costs,
advertising, mail, you name it.
So profit is some subset of this,
but not the totality of it.
So the rate of profit is not the same
thing as the rate of surplus value.
And the right of profit is also not
the same as the rate of exploitation.
But what did he is assuming in the concept
of exploitation is that the worker is
producing some value that ultimately
accrues to the capitalist.
Now I said to you when we started out
talking about marks that he just liked the
neo classical theorists.
He has a micro theory and a macro theory.
You now know what the micro theory is.
It's this story here.
You might think about it.
This diagram is to marks what the parade,
oh diagram is to the parade.
Oh system.
This is the micro story of exploitation
in the same way that the predo system is
the micro theory of market exchanges,
but at the end of the day, of course
it's this a macro theory as well.
As I said,
marks like Adam Smith and David Ricardo
before him had an invisible hand theory
and the,
I think the easiest way to get a grip
on his macro theory is to talk about the
five sources of crisis in capitalist
systems that he thought followed from his
analytical logic.
And I'm just gonna spell them all out now.
Um,
none of them is without its problems
and we'll come back to the problems, uh,
later today and mostly on Wednesday.
But I think it's better first to see
the argument in its totality before we
start, uh, dismembering
it and see what, what, uh,
survives and what doesn't survive
plus or critical scrutiny.
So in the first instance,
one of the possible sources of
crisis is the existence of money.
Now, money from Marx is a
commodity. Like anything else.
This is of course before the era of
paper money and anything like that.
So money is gold or silver or
something like that. And it's,
it's a commodity like any
other commodity. Um, it's,
value is determined by
the cost of producing it.
So gold is valuable because it takes
a lot of work to dig it up basically.
Right? And to refine it. Um,
obviously for a commodity
to function as money,
it's got to have certain properties.
It's got to be easily divisible.
And you know, we use cheap [inaudible]
kind of hard because you know,
if you want to use, you know,
the one, one leg of a sheep, uh,
to represent a three bottles of wine,
they have to kill the sheep,
wouldn't be very convenient.
So money has to be easily
divisible and not, um,
not atrophy and things like that.
But apart from the,
those are its properties as a
use fattier if unite, but as,
as an exchangeable commodity.
It's like anything else.
But once you get to develop market system,
it depends on money to function.
And this,
the ever present possibility
of liquidity crises.
If people start hoarding money and he
thinks that in times of anxiety and so on,
people will start to hoard
money. We saw this, uh, uh,
if you remember during the
financial crisis last year,
whereas suddenly Manx that had trusted
one another for decades and even
centuries,
stop trusting one another and wouldn't
lend money at one money to one another in
ways that they regularly did because
they didn't know whether the other party
had the money to lend.
And there was a period of several weeks
where the entire financial system was in
danger of crashing simply
from the liquidity crisis
that sort of was perched on
top of the credit crisis.
So once the system becomes
completely dependent on money, uh,
as a medium of exchange,
there's the ever present possibility
that people will hoard money and um,
the system will go into a crisis.
Secondly,
Mark's thinks he's now understood better
than Smith and Ricardo before him.
Just why it is that there's a declining
tendency in the rate of profit in
capitalist systems and the,
and the answer is in the,
in the logic of the system you've already
worked your way through. So if we,
if you go back to here as we move down
here to make the system more capital
intensive,
any given move increases profitability
for the person who makes it.
So if this is the status quo and it's a
cotton factory and the capitalists puts
in his spinning Jenny and makes,
um,
makes his wage belt more
quickly than anybody else,
that leads him to be able to
undercut his competitor. Right?
And so his profits will go up,
but all the competitors
all then themselves make
exactly the same innovation
themselves.
And then once once you have spinning
jennies throughout the cotton industry,
the claim is that the rate of profit in
the cotton industry will be lower than
before anybody had put in
a spinning Jenny. Okay.
So that the idea is what you do at the
margin to improve your profits as a
capitalist leads to the declining rate
of profit in the industry as a whole.
Because um,
as we become more and more capital
intensive in the production of cotton,
we have less,
less living human labor power going into
the production of cotton and it's only
living human labor power
that produces fresh value.
Now you might type,
it doesn't,
the Spinning Jenny produce fresh
value Marxist argument is no,
the value of the spinning Jenny was
determined by the Labor to produce the
spinning Jenny and its value
is transferred to the product.
But that's all.
It doesn't produce new value.
It's only the living human labor power.
And the way you need to think about it
is that that is less and less and less of
the capitalists investment as a
proportion of his total investment.
So living human labor power or variable
capitol as Marx calls it is diminishing
proportion of what the capitalist has to
invest in order to remain competitive.
And so overtime profits are going to
diminish in very competitive industries
because they'll get more
and more productive.
And that's what we mean in the modern
world when we say there's a very,
very little margin in
a particular industry,
you want to go into making
something like salad dressing,
very saturated market where
every Gizmo has been tried,
you're going to find miniscule
margins. Uh, very, very hard.
And Mark's thinks this is a
process going on economy wide.
And so that's why economy wide,
the rate of profit gradually declines
in capitalist systems. And as I said,
that's something that all of the
classical economists thought that they had
observed.
And so any theory worth it's name
was going to have to account for it.
So that,
that's the second source of crisis though.
Because as it becomes harder and harder
for capitalists to make a profit,
many of them are going
to go out of business.
And that brings me to the third
source of crises in capitalist systems.
And it's basically that
competition eliminates competitors.
So that the initial market market
model he starts with is a perfectly
competitive one.
But what he's saying is,
of course over time,
as people go out of business,
at the same time as things are becoming
more and more and more capital intensive,
the and other way of putting it,
it's the entry costs become very high.
For instance, in 1984, when
the challenger blew up,
um,
there was a company called Morton Thiokol
making that made the o rings for the
Challenger,
right on the rocket boosters.
It turned out that the design was faulty.
Now you might say,
well that was probably the end of Morton
Thiokol calls relationship with NASA
having, you know, made
such a terrible error.
They would go to a competitor.
But guess why Morton Thiokol is still
making rocket boosters for NASA.
Because you know, the notion that,
um, I would say to myself, hmm,
looks like a good business for me to
get into there. Obviously no good at it.
I'll go start making rocket
boosters for NASA is laughable,
right? Because the entry costs
are so high. So that's an example,
pretty much of an op
monopolistic industry.
So competition leads to innovation.
Yes,
but it also leads to the elimination of
competitors as production becomes more
and more capital intensive.
And once you don't have competitors,
you don't have a reason to innovate.
And the basic dynamic of capitalism
starts to slow down because monopoly
capitalism doesn't have the same
end belt incentives for innovation.
Remember,
the capitalist is not afraid of the worker
on Mark's a story that capitalist is
afraid of the capitol
capitalist down the street.
And once there is no capitalists down the
street about to take his business away
or her business away,
then um,
this competitive dynamic
starts to atrophy.
So that's a third source of
crisis as far as he is concerned.
A fourth source of crisis
that Mark's identifies.
And here he's pretty much
actually following Adam Smith.
The way you can think about it most
straight forwardly is the worker's
collectively,
if they pulled all of their wages,
couldn't buy what they produce.
Okay.
The work has collectively
can buy what they produce.
And that being the case,
this is going to be an endemic problem
of weak demand in capitalist economies.
There's not going to be
enough the man to satisfy.
There's not going to be enough demand
to satisfy the needs of the system in
order,
in order for everything that's
produced to get Saul big problem.
You could say,
well,
doesn't that just mean wages will rise
and then date it does put some upward
pressure on wages. But
as we said, you know,
wages are basically
going to be held around,
consists a subsistence by unemployment.
And so there's not much scope
for that, right? Because if,
if wages start to rise, um, you're,
you're then gonna have the problem that,
uh,
any capitalist who's not in the system
will or would be capitalists to want to
be capitalist.
It's going to come in a Ron unemployed
workers to work for him or her.
And so drive wages down.
So this is a problem. It's,
it's one of the, it's why Adam Smith's
sought you got imperialism, uh,
and indeed Marx and Lenin
after him all thought,
one of the reasons you get imperialism
is to find markets for the goods that are
produced. There were other reasons
too, cheap resources and so on.
But one of the reasons is the
search for new markets, more demand.
Um,
but that's a process which has obvious
limits because eventually you kind of,
you know,
your empire is going to bump into the
French empire in a Belgian empire and the
German Empire, and you're gonna fill
up the world and then what do you do?
So you can stave it off with imperialism.
But the basic underlying problem is that
the work has collectively cannot buy
what they produce.
Now we see this sort of dynamic play
out in some ways during recessions when
there's not enough demand in the economy.
And of course,
there are things you can do about it, can
do what we did in the Great Depression.
The government can borrow
money and give it to, um,
basically give it to unemployed people
by hiring them to do public works and
then they spend it and stimulate
demand. Um, or they can try.
We've been trying to do in
the last year and a half,
they can try and get the banks to give
credit to people to buy things and
stimulate demand.
Um,
but it's a basic structural problem
marks things built into the very fact,
uh, of, uh,
that the built into the system by the
very fact that the work has collectively
cannot produce,
cannot purchase everything
that they produce.
Yeah.
Now you could say,
well these are all sort of tendencies,
but there are counter tendencies as well
and these problems can be staved off
imperialism being an example of staving
off the one I've just discussed and
marks is not particularly clear on just
which one of these problems is supposed
to be decisive.
Rather,
what he thinks is they'll all sort of
kick in and start to make the system creek
and creek at the joints
and not work very well.
And as that starts to happen,
workers will start to get mad because
they will start to discover that the
system isn't giving them
any particular benefits.
The famous line towards the end of the
communist manifesto that you are red
workers will come to realize that they
have nothing to lose, but the chains,
the system that has given
them certain benefits,
we'll give them fewer and fewer benefits.
As competition becomes more cut throat.
Uh,
their employers are working with
narrow or narrow margins. Um, they,
they're unable to buy the huge, the, the,
the luxury goods that
they see all around them.
And so they'll start to become angry.
And that leads us to the
discussion we had last time where,
um, we, we,
we see that Mark's wants to say that the
declining relative share of the total
product is eventually going
to make them militant.
And so the image is office of a
system becoming less and less dynamic.
The smaller and smaller number
of monopolies in every industry.
Capitalists who are going out of business,
falling down into the working class,
bringing all their resentments
with them. And finally, uh,
the system starts to reach the
point where it just can't function.
And that's when he thanks.
The social socialist revolution
becomes both possible and necessary.
And so you will get some sort of
revolutionary moment and the workers,
um,
we'll take over the state and the small
remaining number of monopoly capitalist
will be put out of business.
Uh,
the means of production will
be nationalized and then, uh,
socialism will exist.
So that's the story that he's telling.
Now I want to zero in on a few
features of socialism and communism,
uh,
before we,
and then we'll come back and talk about
the difficulties with this argument.
Socialism for Marx is not an
equilibrium anymore than capitalism is.
Socialism is not a system that is
without its own internal contradictions
according to Marx. And the
reason is as he says, yeah,
we have to deal with
is a communist society.
Not as it's developed on its own
foundations, but on the contrary,
just as it emerges from
a capitalist society,
which is that's in every respect,
economically,
morally and intellectually still stamped
with the birthmarks of the old society
from who's worm. It emerges
accordingly. The individual producer,
this is now, he's talking about after
a socialist revolution producers,
the individual producer receives back
from society after the deductions that
have been made exactly
what he gives to it.
Okay,
so in other way you might put this as
workmanship is no longer hypocritical
under socialism, the work I
really gets back what he's put in,
he receives a certificate from
society that is furnished,
such and such an amount of labor.
Often deducting is labor for the common
funds and with this certificate he draws
from the social stock of mean the of
means of consumption as much as the same
amount of labor cost,
as much as the same amount
of labor costs. So you, so
you have what he,
what he describes,
he has the rights that workers get
to what they've produced. He says
it's still in principle a bourgeois,
right.
Although in principle and practice
on no longer at loggerheads,
while the exchange of equivalence in
commodity exchange exists only on the
average and not in the individual video
case. Don't worry about that last phrase,
but what he's saying here is that
principle and in practice are no longer at
loggerheads.
What he means is the worker is
being recompensed for his work,
right?
Whereas under capitalism,
the worker appears to be being
Rican recompensed for his work,
but in fact some of what he produces
is accruing to the capitalists.
So that's the difference.
Principle and practice are at loggerheads
on to capitalism. It professors,
the idea that we're
entitled to what we make.
Whereas under socialism we
in fact do get what we made
and,
and then that sense socialism is
advanced an advanced on capitalism,
but he says in spite of this advance,
the equal rights is still constantly
stigmatized as a Bush Walker limitation.
The right of the producers is proportional
to the labor they supply and the
equality.
It consists in the fact that that
that measurement is made with an equal
standard labor. Now what
does all that mean? Ah,
it's rather contorted language,
but just look at a little more of the
contorted language and then I'll explain
in words of one syllable what
it means. This is from, uh,
the critique of the Goethe,
the program.
And what he wants to say is even
if you reward people equally,
even if you reward people
equally for their work,
there's going to be inequality
in the society. So he says, look,
one man is superior to another,
physically or mentally and supplies
more labor at the same time,
works harder or can labor for a longer
time and labor to serve as a measure must
be defined by it's duration or intensity.
Otherwise,
it ceases to be a standard of measurement.
This equal rights is an unequal,
right for unequal labor.
So if some of us are stronger than others
and we get paid according to how much
work we do, some of us are
going to get more than others.
Right and equal right to an equal labor.
It recognizes no class differences
because everyone is now only a worker like
everyone else.
Once we get to socialism,
but it tacitly rescue recognizes I
need equal individual endowments.
It passively recognizes
unequal individually endowments
and that's productive
capacity as a natural privilege.
It is therefore a right of
inequality and it's content light.
Every other right,
right by its very nature can consist
only in the application of an equal
standard but unequal individuals.
And they would not be different
individuals if they were not unequal.
A measurable only by an equal standard
insofar as they're brought under an equal
point of view, uh, taken from one
definite side only for instance,
in the present case or regarding only as
work and as as nothing more is seen in
them.
Everything else being ignored further,
one worker is married, another
is not, one has children,
more children than another
and so on and so forth.
Thus with an equal performance of labor
and Henson and equal in the social
consumption fund,
one will in fact received
more than another one will
be richer than another and
so on.
So if you think about a system in which
there's no longer a capitalist but
people are rewarded on the basis of work,
there's still going to be an equality
because some people have more effective
capacities to work than others and because
some have diff have more demands on
them than others. If you have more
children to feed than somebody else,
earning the same amount is going
to leave you relatively worse off.
So socialism is not a condition of
equality because there is this right based
upon labor
and he says these defects are inevitable
and the first phase of a communist
society, which is socialism,
they're inevitable
as it as it is when it is
just emerged off the block.
Prolong Birth Cat Pang from
capitalist society right,
can never be higher than the economic
structure of society and its cultural
development condition.
Their buy in a higher phase of
communist society after the enslaving
subordination of the individual
to the division of labor.
And there with also the antithesis
between mental and physical Labor has
vanished after Labor has become not
only a means of life, but life's prime.
One after the productive
forces have increased with
the all round development of
the individual and the springs of
cooperative wealth law more abundantly,
only then can the narrow horizon and
a bourgeois right be crossed in its
entirety.
And Society subscribe on its banners from
each according to his ability to each
according to his needs,
from each according to his ability
to each according to his needs.
That is the definition of the
distributor principle under communism.
Whereas under socialism,
it's from each according to his
ability to each according to his work.
So socialism is not hypocritical with
respect to the the workmanship ideal
because unlike capitalism, the workers
getting rewarded for their work,
but it's still an unequal society
because people are differently abled and
people have different demands to meet.
Uh,
and so finally we have to get to the
abolition of the very idea of rights in
order to get to the communist idea of
from each according to his ability to each
according to his need.
So that's the Marxian story.
I'm sorry I put such long quotations
up there, but I think you,
you need them to get a flavor of how he
was actually thinking about it. Th the,
these interaction crises,
all of them making one another
worst declining profits,
a liquidity crisis, more and
more militant workers, um,
and, and so on and so forth. Finally,
you get an increase in consciousness.
The socialists takeover.
It's still an unequal system,
but it has the capacity
for super abundance,
for cooperative wealth
to flow more abundantly.
And so we can abolish the idea of right
completely and just distribute on the
basis of needs.
Now
I want to start digging into
this in a critical way, um,
to show you all of the things
that are wrong with it.
But this is in the spirit of
how we treated utilitarianism.
Uh, that is to say we're going to see
all of the things that are wrong with his
argument in the same way that we did with
Bentham and mill in order then to see
if there's any surviving intuition.
And I want to start with
this concept of needs.
One of the reasons
Marx and his followers,
we're so focused on needs
was that they were convinced that
in order to keep itself going,
capitalism,
manufacturers
pseudo wants all the time. We
already saw this, this problem.
You know, there's this problem
with insufficient demand.
You've got to get people to want things.
You've got to get people to believe,
you know,
if you don't have the latest,
whatever it is,
you're a schmuck.
Uh,
you know,
my son, you know, looks at my
blackberry tour and he says,
how can you use a phone like that?
Nobody uses those anymore.
You've got to have a Google phone, right?
And if you don't have a Google phone,
you're just a complete loser.
That's his view of the matter. Uh,
and because there's this problem,
weak demand,
this is built in emphasis to constantly
manufacturer demand fourth and things
that nobody needs.
But the impulse to create all of these,
these phony needs will go away.
Why don't you don't need
capitalism to innovate?
So why don't you don't have capitalism.
You don't need people to constantly
think that they have to have the latest
Gizmo. You don't need to try and get
people to think, you know, of the,
of the 27 kinds of, um, dishwashing
liquid in stop and shop.
This one's better than that one.
Um,
all of these manufactured artificial
needs are an artifact of the problem that
we have to keep capitalism going.
And once that goes away,
we can think about people
having finite needs.
And so if society late reaches
a certain level of abundance,
then those needs can be met.
Who thinks that's a terrible
argument? Okay. What's bad about it?
Take,
take the,
yeah.
Yeah.
It just doesn't seem like a good model
of human nature puts a limit on how much
you can want it. What it puts a limit
on how much you can want. And it makes,
it seems like everyone has to
want the same amount of things.
Okay. Why else? That I think that was a
good point. What else is wrong with it?
I mean, it is surely it's true
that some of the things, you know,
there is a difference between
wants and needs. Right?
And a lot of our wants are very
frivolous, right? You're not, you,
there are a lot of things do we want,
I mean the neoclassical system doesn't
differentiate because it's all,
we don't allow interpersonal judgments
of utility, right? So, uh, you know,
Trump thinks that he needs the next
$100 million and you might say he might,
he might want it, but
he doesn't need it. But
what's wrong with,
you know,
I'm just wanting you to elaborate
on what he was saying. Well,
somebody else to elaborate on,
on what she was saying. Yeah,
no.
How the government will decide what
people need and what they just want.
You're,
you're,
you're troubled by the idea of that
government deciding what people will need
and want. They just want, I think
that's fair enough. But you know,
I think Marx and his most
utopian moments after all,
one of the differences between social
zone communism is there is no government
under communism is a withering away
of the state. So his idea I think,
is this just going to be all the super,
these, you know, all these goodies.
Every people,
we'll just take what they need.
Where does the abundance come from also?
That's another problem.
Where is it? It's been made
possible by capitalism. The they,
the productivity of cap,
it gets used up and then there is
no more capitalism to create more.
Okay.
So you're saying it'll,
we might go to super abundance
but then go fall back from it. So,
uh, yeah, those, those, uh, I
think those are good criticism.
So why will there be continuing abundance?
I think that's a fair criticism.
Um,
but I think there's a more fundamental
problem with it and that is
in distinguishing wants from needs.
You could say luck,
you know,
even before you get to those problems,
which you both raise
serious questions for it.
But even before you get to those
question, somebody might say, look,
we can at least define needs by what
people require in order to survive.
Surely if we want
to distinguish one's from needs,
we,
we make a distinction between
things that if you don't get them,
you're going to die versus things
that if you don't get them,
you might not be that happy,
but you're not going to die.
What about that? Is that,
who thinks that that would
solve Marxists problem?
Anybody?
Why wouldn't it? Who thinks it
wouldn't? You just said, you know,
we've got to reach a level of productivity
where we can produce what people in
need in order to survive
and then we could get rid of the
regime of rights. And you know, he,
I think Mark's makes a very valid point
when he says any regime of riots is a
regime of inequality.
Yeah.
Well I think there's kind of keeping
with the same thing they had during, um,
capitalism. Like if it's
still just subsistence level,
if that's what you need.
And that's the same thing the workers
had under capitalism is not really making
the communism a better
society for the people.
Okay. So you're saying, oh,
a world in which people only meet their
needs may not be a better world. Yeah.
Okay. I think that might be
a fact, a fair criticism.
He wants to say the alternative is that
we're all like these rats on wheels
running faster and faster
to get, um, you know,
less and less benefit.
So the,
that and last we can accept
finitude that, you know, we,
we live for a fixed time
and, and uh, we, we,
if we, if we can't come to
grips with the fact that, um,
we are finite creatures,
we're never going to be happy.
So I think that's the debate that
he would want to have with you.
But I think that that even within
Marx's own terms of reference,
this a, this a different
problem and that that is this.
Suppose you said, all right. We all grant
you as a matter of the philosophy on it.
We'll grant you the proposition.
We'll grant you call marks the proposition
that needs are defined by what is
necessary for people's
survival and that they,
they should somehow be more important
than and Trump frivolous once that might
make life better. But still, you know,
still an all making my life better
by letting me have a nice car is less
important than preventing somebody from
starving when it really gets down to it.
And so we could make this distinction
between needs and wants in that sense.
But here's the problem.
Even if we're only trying to meet people's
needs defined in that narrow sense of
keeping people alive,
there's still and Damick scarcity.
This notion of super abundance
doesn't make any sense.
Just think about it for a minute.
Money that we spend on
dialysis machines
is money that we don't spend on
heart transplants or aids research.
So no matter what,
no matter how much wealth there is this
still distributed choices to make and
this society, there's still gonna be the
problem that we're going to say, wow,
if we choose to to to protect needs a,
B,
and c that need anyone who needs
dialysis should get free dialysis.
Then in, you know, whether we make it
explicit or implicit beside the point,
somebody who needs something else to
keep them alive is not going to get it.
We're not going to do research on cancer
because we are doing spending that next
marginal dollar doing research on um,
the causes of AIDS. Um, so why,
why don't you see that point then
the notion of super abundance becomes
incoherent.
There is no such thing as super
abundance and without super abundance,
you can't get a world beyond entitlements,
right?
But it explicit or implicit,
you're never going to transcend
the world of scarcity.
Why don't you see that that meeting
needs even defined in this minimal way of
what's necessary to keep people
alive re involves trade offs.
What you're really saying is that scarcity
is endemic to the human condition.
And this is the deepest analytical
floor in Marx's normative theory.
Because once you say that scarcity
is endemic to the human condition,
you can't get away from
distributor of conflict.
You've got to find some way,
whether it's a system of rights,
whether it's the market,
where it's the government making
decisions about who needs what, um,
somebody or some mechanism is
gonna make those decisions,
right?
So you reach the proposition that scarcity
is endemic to the human condition and
you have to reason about what makes sense.
Taking that for granted.
Anyway,
it's ironic that Marx was so blind to
this because Mark's was the person who
said human nature is not static
and evolves through history.
We develop and change.
Um,
and so you would think he of all people
would see that the, the fact that,
you know,
in 1886,
the natural life expectancy
was whatever it was, 46 years.
Why that shouldn't be taken as a given
or the biblical three score years and 10
be taken as a given for that matter.
Um,
but you will never reach a condition
in which scarcity can be transcended.
And that's the ultimate
hope behind his utopianism.
So it's not that I disagree with
any of the points you folks made.
I think they're all correct.
The other,
there are other reasons
that you would question it,
but the reason this
particular, uh, argument,
I think cuts at the roots of his
theory is that it's the most favorable
interpretation of his account of needs,
right?
There's no more favorable interpretation
than limiting them to survival.
And even on that account,
we can't,
we can't get to a world
of super abundance.
We will always live in
a world of scarcity.
And that means that whatever you have to
say about distribution has to take that
for granted. This is, this is as I think,
as powerful at point as the point we
made when we came to the end of our
discussion of mill to the effect that
you can't get the politics out of the
definition of harm,
right?
There's no neutral way to define harm.
Uh,
another way of thinking about this is it's
a way of trying to transcend politics,
right? One of angles, not
marks, but nevermind, uh,
angles was,
um,
stating a Marxian and view was that the,
the great thing about a socialism and
communism is that politics gets displaced
by administration.
That you don't have to worry
about distributive conflict
in this story because
there's super abundance,
right? And in mills account,
you don't have to worry about the
definition of harm in his case because
there'll be a neutral scientific
account. Uh, neither of them works.
So we have a world in which they have to
be political choices about distributed
questions.
Some say leave it to the market,
but that is itself a political choice.
We'll,
we'll have more to say about that.
So that's the,
the beginning of the end of Marxism is
I think the recognition that scarcity is
endemic to the human condition.
Um,
what we will do on Wednesday is explore
and unpack some other difficulties with
his argument and then see where the,
and what the remaining insights might be.
See you then.